I like mystery I like unexplained things
to me it makes the world richer it makes
it it makes it cooler if there's stuff
in the world
I mean Lovecraft who I made these notes
to created this cosmology that he never
explained you know there were common
references to stories and the he hinted
at unspeakable mysteries and histories
and you know vast Aeons of of lost
civilizations and alien races and Dark
Gods living among us but it was all very
disturbing and very mysterious and very
evocative
after he died August Derleth who was
another writer and a huge Lovecraft fan
completed many of his in completed
stories and really regularized this der
les was not nearly the writer Lovecraft
was but he was a very methodical man so
he went through when he came up with
well here's how you put all this
together and here's the entire history
of all of the denizens of the Lovecraft
world and here they all related to each
other
and to my mind he completely missed the
point that that never should have been
done here we didn't need the history of
the great old ones and how they related
to the ancient ones and you know where
the young earth came into it and and all
of that they were much better when they
were just evocative and mysterious and
disturbing than when he put them all in
a in a you know theology with morning
comes miss ball obviously it's about
that very idea
I find the mysteries obviously it's
something that many people are very
interested in and obviously in the
novels you have mysteries of the past
mysteries about far places you also have
mysteries very present about current
things I mean the first book is you know
who killed John Oran and you know who
really tried to kill bran does mystery
fiction is that something of one of the
genres you're really interested in or is
it just the idea of mystery in general
that leads you to put that kind of well
I do like mystery mystery fiction that
you know the present-day mysteries and
Ice and Fire will be resolved most
but I also like a certain but you know
the ancient histories of you know what
what lies beyond the dark curtain and
where the gods came from no I'm not
gonna bring any gods on on stage I'm not
gonna give you a complete history of
Sethe Oreos
you know you the mysteries of yean will
have to remain mysterious and and for
people to you know to wonder about
themselves I think they're they're left
better that way a little a little more
mysterious and and cool what was I gonna
say about them the mysteries of yeah I
do also believe in a certain amount of
ambiguity and and subtlety you know
going through this museum you look at
the display on on King Carla 12th who
was shot in the head and no one knows
whether he was shot in the head by the
enemy or his own men we don't know that
it's ambiguous it's right there in
display maybe he was killed by two
Swedes and maybe but in Norwegians he
was fighting who killed them we'll never
know so if that's true in life
why shouldn't be true in fiction you
know what happened to the two princes in
the tower you know people were arguing
about that you know five hundred years
later who killed them were they killed
well they smuggle that and say of to
knows why shouldn't we have similar
mysteries in fiction that we can argue
about and wonder about since they exist
in real life
I just curious to follow up then sort of
as an author II when you introduce a
mystery that you want to relieve the
ambiguous do you have the answer
yourself all the time or do you leave it
ambiguous to yourself as well I in the
vast majority of cases I know the answer
to you know things like who killed Jon
Arryn and all of that sometimes I had
the answer when I unfolded in the book I
do it fairly subtly you know I I don't
tend to write the classic detective
scene where you know everybody gets
together in one room when he says and
here are the clues and I have put them
together because I am Ellery Queen or
Sherlock Holmes or whatever and or
Perrault and here is what my little gray
cells have told me but the answer is
there if the reader is paying attention
and you can put it together yourself
so yes the movies always scarier before
you see the monster basically